now to ukraine russia's pledge yesterday
to stop shelling certain areas to help
build a trust was too good to be true
ukrainian officials say the bombardment
continues near kiev and the northern
city of cherniv the peace talks changed
nothing and today the white house said
it believes it's increasingly clear
russia's invasion has been a strategic
blunder and that vladimir putin is being
misinformed by his advisors about how
badly the russian military is performing
redmond shannon reports and a warning
some of the images in his story are
disturbing
the governor of the chernhiv region in
northern ukraine describing a night of
air strikes just hours after russia said
it would drastically scale back attacks
there and in kiev the capital's mayor
had a similar message
yesterday information right now the
russian forces move
away from kiev it's not true all night
with listen observances means reckless
attack few insider outside ukraine are
surprised by the broken promise i don't
think you can trust what is coming out
of the mouth of putin's war machine
ukraine's neutrality proposal coming out
of tuesday's talks in istanbul
apparently not enough for russia
moscow's chief negotiator saying the two
sides are still far apart on the future
of crimea and donbass reports wednesday
say u.s intelligence believes russian
president vladimir putin was misinformed
about the extent of russia's military
struggles on the ground
this village near harkev now back under
ukrainian control according to the
regional governor
we are pushing them back slowly but
steadily says this soldier but in
battered and surrounded mariupol a
different story and a demand from putin
that a ukrainian surrender is the best
way to save the tens of thousands of
people stuck in the city the un says
russia's actions there may amount to war
crimes people are living in sheer terror
the situation is worsening by the day
with constant shelling president
vladimir zelinsky is demanding europe
shut all its seaports to russian ships
just as russia has blocked ports like
mariupol his u.s counterpart joe biden
has pledged an additional half a billion
dollars in aid
some of it for humanitarian aid for
marijuana evacuees like dima
he cries out for his father both were
injured in shelling and are now in
different hospital wards all the nurse
can do is assure him his dad will come
soon redmond shannon global news london